so 2014 is almost over and the game
selection was super interesting well it
was okay it was fine okay so 2014 in
video games was not exactly impressive
if you're hoping to feel a little better
about the year that was though it's time
for my favorite video of the year here's
five games from 2014 that is so terrible
they make everything else seem way
better soulcalibur may be a popular
household name for fighting game fans
but this year's entry lost swords on ps3
was nowhere near deserving of the
franchise the free-to-play game could be
forgiven since you didn't have to fork
out any dollars up front but the
reliance on badly implemented
microtransactions which gave the game a
distinct pay2win feel really grounded
lost swords in this list of terribleness
particularly since pay2win extends to
pay to play since you have to buy action
points to undertake quests otherwise you
have to wait for your action points to
recharge alongside that giant problem
the game is also peppered with really
long load times as well as the notable
absence of multiplayer which really
doesn't look good for a one-on-one
fighting game don't play it just don't
do it
since we're already talking games that
ruined well-loved franchises from your
childhood we've better get on to sonic
boom rise of lyric you probably remember
my segment about the horrible sonic 2006
game and while this isn't quite as bad
it's definitely trying to achieve
similar lows of disappointing shittyness
our reviewer Don sass gave the game a
whopping 2 out of 10 citing unwieldy
controls are broken camera repetitive
levels or in combat and a lack of
responsiveness you know totally the
opposite of what you want out of a
platformer that doesn't sound
rage-inducing at all it's also been
called ugly and poorly written with a
choppy frame rate and many bugs so
anything you can think of that games do
this one did badly let's get out of here
you know what almost never disappoints
video games based on movies wait it's
the opposite of that and while we're on
the topic Rambo the video game is a
special breed of a in my broken games
video i said that superman 64 made
flying not fun well Rambo the video game
actually manages to make shooting not
fun in a game what could possibly make
being an unstoppable badass killing
machine unbearably dull well the fact
that the whole thing is on Rails is a
huge contributor expect to mildly push
about your crosshair to shoot stuff and
do that and only that oh so with a light
gun game I hear you ask no no light gun
support sensible
remember bomberman the nostalgia
eliciting strategic Maisie goodness
that's loads of fun and an absolute
classic well this game is exactly like
that game except it's bad in every way
the basic gameplay mechanics of basement
crawl for the ps4 are actually okay
probably because it's ripping off
Bomberman but there's very little else
there it's sort of trying to beat clone
and a horror game and nine other things
all at the same time and achieves
exactly none of them it's broken it's
unfinished it belongs exactly where its
name suggests in the basement never to
be played again even the dev Bluebird
team felt bad promising to remake it
under the title of basement brawl and
have the hopefully less crap version
available to purchases of the original
game for free it's probably pretty
obvious why you haven't seen this one
heavily publicized in sony's press
conferences so i guess that makes it
time for air control i'm assuming you've
probably already heard my spiel on this
horrific game that actually made it to
steam a few weeks back so instead of
telling you about it again i decided to
play it because that seemed like a good
idea when i wrote the script well [ __ ]
mother okay i'm falling that's what's
happening bowling oh look a little car
oh is it learning or crashing is that
learning or crashing what
up down left right to change direction
um what oh about a hundred evidential at
length of life oh my god my god I mean
all those eights oh good we're flying
again what what change weapons oh my god
holy [ __ ] what oh I reject your reality
and substitute with land well that makes
sense let me know what you guys think is
the worst of the worst is it one of the
games on this list or something
completely different and be sure to let
me know what you thought of this year's
game selection leave me your thoughts
and I'll be back next week not playing
air control